20:17 has been a bittersweet year for
Fergie not only did she release her
first solo album in over a decade called
double duchess but she also announced
her separation from her husband of eight
years Josh Duhamel
that's right Cheryl and this Sunday you
can watch Fergie tear up the stage at
the iHeartRadio Jingle Ball North
special but tonight she tears it up with
Sangeeta and reflects on her very
emotional year how would you describe
this year for you a lot of work a lot of
work and a lot of learning how to
balance everything takes time and to be
a mom it's like it's it's either work or
actual work or axel or I'm in the gym
you know what I mean I would like to get
a little bit more free time to just
chill cuts around one of the things too
as a mother you're so busy with axel
yeah that you start for your career but
do you have time for yourself like who
do you turn to to take care of you well
I do a lot of these um the Oprah D pop
meditation those 21 day they've been
really helpful for me during this album
I got it first as a present from
somebody and she thought I needed to
meditate but the one that I love is
called desire and destiny once you gave
me and it's I've done it like now I'm
probably like seven times can just
recenter something it helps and every
good therapists good but yeah but we
need to get where our sessions yeah we
need to do a therapy session right oh
yeah
[Applause]
bro
I love the sign you're so real and he
means a lot to me and I think I'm even a
mother to mother and everything you've
done oh yeah you too
but the idea and concept that you you
thought about your son for the last year
and you know you kept her separation to
yourself and it's liberating now to let
people know that you what you went
through over the year it is it's free
not only just being able to speak freely
about everything but just to get this
album out you know with all that
anticipation and it's funny because
everyone tells you like put up the
up-tempo get them going but it's
interesting that people have really
gravitated towards wanting to hear those
who are vulnerable just honest songs and
it's great because when me as an artist
like I've always had those songs that
get me through hard times our breakups
or any of those and I want to really
feel it and I want to give you those
exact words and if I can be that for
people
that's what more can I ask for it's the
best thing ever
just save it tomorrow holidays coming up
holiday traditions for you holiday
traditions well right now we see you
cooking we're doing we're doing Elf on
the Shelf nice and he you know he's
coming this year so we get to see every
morning where he pops up from the North
Pole flying the night before so so
that's always fun and we're gonna do
gingerbread house and I love waking up
and seeing what Santa brought under the
tree what's the one under the tree fine
I just want to see axel run around
hitting open his presents that's the big
pleasure for me and I remember doing
that as a kid so it's just it's the
cutest happy holiday
thank you thank you thank you so much
and I just want to say this girl's arms
I know you put time in the gym and
you're a mom so I'm proud of you I know
that you're you're working it out Thank
You lieutenant eat milk mom I like to
follow